io nasco nel 1980 quindi per iniziare la
mia storia parte da qui il novecento
viene conosciuto viene spesso definito
the century of self il secolo dell'io
viene definito in questo modo perché il
secolo dell'affermazione soprattutto in
campo economico delle teorie di mercato
e non liberiste come diceva john maynard
keynes spesso la motivazione danaro ci
ha spinto nel corso del tempo a vedere
come diciamo ad associare a chi utilizza
il danaro degli aggettivi che scendo io
insomma gli vedessimo associate delle
persone che ci stanno vicino insomma ci
creerebbe non pochi fastidi
pensiamo a fondo noi pensiamo al danaro
pensiamo all'individualismo e
all'egoismo alla competizione
all'avidità al profitto al cinismo al
potere al materialismo ma effettivamente
queste qualità sono indispensabili per
quanto concerne quella visione che la
visione economicistica del mondo in cui
questo homo economicus che un uomo
perfettamente razionale si muove per
massimizzare il proprio profitto da dove
deriva questa convinzione deriva insomma
dalla dal pensiero
almeno così ci raccontano molto spesso
di questo economista qua che si chiama
adam smith nella ricchezza delle nazioni
questo è uno dei passaggi che viene più
spesso strumentalizzato a questo
proposito ci cosa diceva smith non è
dalla generosità del macellaio del
birraio del fornaio che noi possiamo
sperare di ottenere il nostro pranzo ma
dalla valutazione che si fanno dei
propri interessi
questo uomo qui però oltre a scrivere la
ricchezza della nazione scrive un altro
libro che si intitola teoria dei
sentimenti morali e cosa dice qual è
l'interesse di ogni uomo
l'interesse di ogni uomo è la simpatia
simpatia significa per l'appunto vivere
insieme agli altri le mozioni e degli
altri quindi significa
dividere in un certo qual modo significa
infatti a riconoscersi nell'altro quindi
vedete come vedete spesso alcuni dei
dogmi delle convinzioni che accompagnano
l'economia di mercato l'economia il neo
liberista non sono altro che dei
fraintendimenti delle
strumentalizzazioni
lo stesso concetto di efficienza pensate
tutti quanti in nome dell'efficienza
siamo disposti a sopportare qualsiasi
tipo di fatica questa è una definizione
di economia che trovate su internet sui
libri sui testi di scuola l'economia e
la scienza che studia la locazione di
risorse limitate tra usi alternativi al
fine di massimizzare la soddisfazione
ovvero il profitto dell'individuo il co
agire individualistico razionale ci
dicono porti alla migliore soddisfazione
dei bisogni collettivi
quello che dobbiamo chiederci in che
modo questo processo avviene a questo
punto dobbiamo anche chiederci se è vero
che gli unici bisogni che vengono presi
in considerazione dell'economia sono i
bisogni coperti da beni finanziari in
che modo il consumatore che il sovrano
di un'economia di mercato che decreta il
successo o meno di un prodotto di
un'attività imprenditoriale volta la
mercato krazia ahi noi non è una
democrazia mentre in una democrazia per
ogni testa c'è un voto nella mercato
krazia per ogni unità di moneta per ogni
dollaro per ogni euro c'è un volto come
ben sapete questi voti non sono
distribuiti equamente nella popolazione
ma a questo punto noi ci siamo chiesti
se questo voto avviene attraverso la
moneta dovremmo magari cercare di capire
assieme che cos'è la moneta
prima abbiamo visto che spesso ci
rapportiamo alle cose come se fossero
direbbe sirl in questo filosofo dei
fatti brutti ovvero delle cose che
esistono oltre noi ma se noi ci
rapportiamo al danaro come a qualcosa
che esiste al di là di noi come se fosse
il vento o una montagna allora non siamo
in grado di capire che il danaro e un
costrutto antropico e che possiamo
cambiare e cambiare il modo attraverso
cui viene distribuito quindi cambiare le
regole del credito
a cambiare le regole stesse attraverso
cui la moneta viene creata e distribuita
e attraverso cui si muove quindi se io
chiedessi in questa sala l'ho fatto
centinaia di volte che cos'è la moneta
otterrà e centinaia di risposte diverse
l'una dall'altra
neanche la scienza economica ha dato una
risposta univoca questa domanda il
rapporto che noi abbiamo con il danaro e
lo stesso rapporto che sant'agostino
diceva l'uomo ha col tempo se nessuno me
lo chiede diceva nelle confessioni di
sant'agostino so cos'è se interrogato
devo rispondere non so cos'è e allora
noi siamo proprio partiti da lì e si
comanda il 1971 non in tanti lo sanno ma
vengono sospesi gli accordi di bretton
woods
quindi dietro il danaro non c'è più
neanche la promessa di convertibilità
che la propria del dollaro in oro ma c'è
semplicemente un accordo fa parte della
costruzione della realtà sociale
diciamo che fa parte di una sorta di
coscienza del noe quindi di un accordo
pertanto noi ci siamo ritrovati nella
definizione per cui il danaro un accordo
all'interno di una comunità che decide
di utilizzare un dato mezzo un dato
strumento come mezzo di scambio
a questo punto vi direte e voi in che
modo avete interpretato questa cosa
chiaramente la prima cosa che viene da
pensare in tanti ce lo dicono ci dicono
potete immaginare all'inizio della
nostra avventura nel 2007 iniziamo a
immaginare sar decs io vengo da un
paesino di 10mila abitanti ha detto che
eravamo la seconda provincia medio
campidano più povera d'italia
iniziamo a pensare sarde nel 2009
diventiamo la prima quindi come dire già
la situazione inizia a migliorare
a questo punto cosa succede scoppia la
crisi economico finanziaria e sapevamo
che dalla crisi economica sarebbero
derivate due cose carenza di liquidità è
stretta creditizia
noi venivamo da una situazione in
sardegna di credit crunch di difficoltà
di accesso al credito
quindi non aveva un'idea di cosa sarebbe
venuto dopo
pertanto ci siamo opposti la prima
domanda che è molto sentito
mio padre il giorno dopo la caduta di
lehman brothers ha preso si è alzato e
andato al lavoro per lui non era
cambiato nulla
la sua azienda in grado di produrre le
altre aziende in grado di produrre ed
eravamo lì con i nostri bisogni intatti
quindi nel momento in cui noi siamo in
grado di produrre cosa veramente
importante trovare il modo di continuare
a scambiarci i beni o servizi
quindi la mancanza di moneta non è un
problema
sarebbe come dire direbbe qualcuno che
non possiamo costruire una strada perché
mancano i km
esattamente la stessa cosa
cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo creato un
sistema di credito reciproco ci siamo
ispirati principalmente a due esperienze
un e l'esperienza della banca vir che
nasce nel 34 in svizzera e inizia un
sistema di scambio dove ha seguito la
crisi del 29 per sempre per via della
mancanza di liquidità le imprese
contabilizzavano ogni volta che
acquistavano un credito è un debito nei
confronti delle altre imprese che
partecipavano a questo circolo economico
e ogni volta che vendevano
contabilizzavano invece un credito nei
confronti di queste imprese
oltre a questo ci siamo ispirati a un
altro progetto che diciamo fondamentale
nella storia dell'economia che la
proposal for international che di union
di john maynard keynes games che si
occupa per tutta la vita di relegare il
problema economico ma un problema di
secondaria importanza dice dobbiamo
riscrivere i rapporti tra debitori e
creditori
in che modo trattandosi metricamente
debitori e creditori
poi vedremo in che modo questo ha
influenzato il nostro progetto
come funziona molto semplice un sardo
equivale ad un euro
la prima si è parlato di moneta virtuale
in realtà mi preme dirvi che si tratta
di una moneta digitale virtuale deriva
dal latino virtuali se significa
nient'altro che in potenza qualcosa che
in potenza deve essere reso in atto da
questo punto di vista l'unica proprietà
in potenza che il danaro ha in sé e il
valore in che modo viene attualizzata
nel momento in cui chiediamo il danaro
nei confronti di un bel
quindi il danaro e valore in potenza e
vi viene in atto non nel suo possesso
ma nel suo cederlo ad un altro comunque
un sarde equivale ad un euro
a questo punto io mi iscrivo alla rete
potete immaginare e costruire una rete
da zero cosa è significato siamo andati
a raccontare il progetto a centinaia di
imprese finalmente troviamo un pazzo che
ci dice sì ci sto chi siamo
tu sei il momento dopodiché da lì
abbiamo cercato di coinvolgere sempre
più imprese e nel giro di un anno
avevamo 250 imprese
l'impresa comunque si iscrive e mette a
disposizione dei beni o servizi
i beni e servizi che vengono richiesti
dalla rete ogni volta che attende riceve
un credito ogni volta che invece
acquista contabilizza un debito ma la
possibilità di scendere sul suo conto e
quindi di acquistare ancor prima di aver
venduto attraverso un affidamento che è
la collettività a dargli quindi che
l'insieme delle imprese iscritte
questo cambia completamente i rapporti
ed a bilaterale il rapporto fiduciario
diventa multilaterale ovvero ogni
credito ogni stretta di mano all'interno
del circuito un atto di fiducia tra il
singolo alla comunità e la comunità e il
singolo
siamo partiti con il business to
business quindi con le imprese per poi
andare avanti secondo una logica che
pian piano ha conquistato migliaia di
imprese
vedremo sono tremila alle imprese
vedremo i numeri ma qual è questa logica
la logica che nel sistema che viviamo ci
sono due spinte contrapposte ovvero
debitore e creditore vivono due spinte
contrapposte per ogni credito c'è un
debito
questo significa che io creditore sarò
spinto dal fatto che un primo di
tesorizzato ne ho degli interessi ad
accumulare sempre più credito questo
impedisce al debitoria di ripagare il
suo debito
quello che abbiamo fatto e trattare
simmetricamente debitori e creditori
quindi eliminare l'interesse eliminare
il tratto di liquidità della moneta per
far sì che il creditore fosse portato a
spendere al più presto il suo credito e
mettesse in condizione il debitoria in
questo modo di ripagare il proprio
debito in una spinta che portale
equilibrio
l'unica posizione sensata nel circuito
sarde e stare attorno allo zero se io
accumulo un miliardo di fantastic
milioni di sarde sono un deficiente
tutto qui scegli o perché gli devo
spendere per nient'altro
abbiamo poi deciso di far entrare un
circuito i dipendenti delle imprese
perché perché erano venuti a mancare
quelli che sono secondo me delle cose
fondamentali da un lato tutti i bonus e
i premi per il lavoro straordinario non
c'erano più soldi non si potevano più
dare li abbiamo ripristinato in crediti
questo significa maggiore potere
d'acquisto per le famiglie significa
spingere sulla domanda aggregata di beni
o servizi locali e fare in modo che
nascano delle relazioni forti tra
dipendenti e imprenditori quindi dopo
aver lavorato sulle relazioni tra
imprenditori abbiamo lavorato nelle
relazioni tra imprenditori e ai propri
lavoratori
ma non solo i lavoratori hanno
un'opportunità straordinaria quella di
chiedere anticipazioni sulle
retribuzioni future e abbiamo visto
veramente dipendenti chiedere
anticipazioni per qualsiasi cosa da una
ristrutturazione della casa a un
matrimonio fino alle spese dentistiche
perché oggi come oggi in una famiglia
monoreddito anche affrontare le spese
dentistiche diventa difficile l'ultimo
passaggio sarà quello l'ingresso dei
cittadini
in che modo fare mentre i cittadini i
cittadini che sceglieranno di premiare
le imprese del circuito riceveranno dei
bonus in crediti spendibili inediti
sarde spendibili all'interno della rete
questi sono i risultati che abbiamo
ottenuto
come potete vedere 170 mila operazioni
dietro ogni operazione una stretta di
mano basata sulla fiducia tra due
imprenditori si esce dall'anonimato
quando uno pagan sarde è diverso perché
si va da pagare in euro
nessuno mi chiede cosa fai tu cosa fai
anche cup che cavolo te frega qui da voi
no se tu vai e paghi in sarde la domanda
è spontanea e tu di cosa ti occupi a io
faccio questo perché si rientra in una
dimensione umana 90 milioni di euro di
transazioni negli ultimi tre anni di cui
42 solo quest'anno velocità di
circolazione cos'è la velocità
attraverso cui credi ti passano di mano
in mano una moneta fatta per essere
spesa circa
ma non se la tiene nessuno 12,35 euro
1,5
1120 per cento la crescita del sistema
delle transazioni nel sistema
in questi anni quando abbiamo iniziato
non avremmo mai immaginato di vedere
quello che è successo di collaborare con
con lei il di collaborare con la london
school of economics che stanno studiando
il nostro modello di essere invitati
come succederà il 7 di dicembre dalle
nazioni unite a parlare della diffusione
del mondo del modello nei paesi
emergenti
ma ciò che ci aspettavamo e così è stato
e di vedere che all'interno delle
persone la collaborazione quindi il
bisogno di collaborazione era forte
qua potete vedere il network l'analisi
del nostro network in cui come vi dicevo
ognuno dei link tra questi nodi una
stretta di mano tra imprese del circuito
pertanto quello che noi vogliamo fare è
accompagnare il sistema economico
associando alla moneta che usiamo tutti
i giorni un altro strumento che altre
funzioni accompagnarlo dal secolo
dell'io al secolo del noe passare dal do
ut des al do ut posses dare quindi fare
in modo che io ti do affinché tu possa
dare ad altri perché se in futuro a
community sul bidet neal currencies
quindi le comunità saranno la nuova
moneta la fiducia reciproca e la
collaborazione saranno le basi per
costruire un modello di sviluppo
sostenibile e duraturo e io vi ringrazio